good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy thursday hope
everyone's having a great day hey jax
how you doing i'm doing good because for
us this thursday is quite like a friday
last show of the week i'm feeling so
good and excited about it ready to give
it my all and leave it all at the toast
you know i'm wearing my friday outfit
because it's a thursday that feels like
a friday my outfit too is something that
i would wear on a friday because it's
like you know a very cozy outfit i have
my cozy shoes on i really got dressed
with friday in mind so everyone if
you're watching sorry
yeah no it's just friday's more of a
mentality yeah also just like take
tomorrow off yeah you deserve it yeah
some fridays a little mental health day
yeah love to hear it well i hope
everyone had a great day yesterday's
episode was just full of information you
know i'm kind of
i know this is not about me and don't
worry that's something i'm struggling
with but um i'm just kind of
decompressing from the last few days
it's been a whirlwind of attention are
you ever just like relieved to have it
not be about you
you know what i mean no i feel like like
you don't like
it must be nice that it's like so much
attention it's like you don't even have
to yeah i guess it's true like i'm
reaping a lot of the benefits of your
pregnancy just like clout chasing you
yeah and it does feel good right yeah
there's pros and cons for sure like i
don't have to carry a baby right to term
i'm good
you get to go drinking tonight having
sushi and getting spray tans no i
actually am getting a spray tan and i
was supposed to go drinking tonight but
i'm
this [ __ ] close to throwing my back
out and have to get on a plane tomorrow
so i've got to relax you do muscle relax
muscle relax yeah take a bath take a
pill
honestly you know i'm on this journey
too
yes
get out of the bath
bath then pill yeah i'm on this journey
to see the snow before christmas and i'm
also on a journey i've just i guess i
knew that my bathtub wasn't an ideal
size when i moved in but i guess you
know i have
increased in size with thin length well
width
and
another part of my journey to see the
snow before christmas in a hopefully
brand new apartment is i need a tub that
fits my needs you should come over and
use my tub
so sick i've got a nice tub no i
actually can't even come over to your
apartment with a view you have a tub
with a view a tub that is so sunken into
the ground you can get lost in there i
really could but no like you know i have
to use my core to stay up when like i'm
chilling in the tub yeah it's so hard
for me you know how like when we were
kids we'd go to the beach and you would
say like i'm digging a hole so far on
the ground you'll go to china like yeah
if you go all the way down in your
bathtub you come out in shanghai like
it's so deep it is you should come
borrow it sometime i should but then
it's like i have to waddle home wet like
you sleep over you don't have an extra
bed we'll sleep together okay bring the
boys
the boys being due and brew
yeah of course
not meet you zach and ben in a bed
together oh no oh no no no no no no
speaking of dew and brew both boys could
not make it today i can only speak for
brew we're recording after there's
another episode for patreon q a about
pregnancy taking all of your questions
and we're also recording it as a video
because some people requested that so
we're like sure yeah we should do that
more often because it's just like a
regular episode it's gonna feel like a
regular episode just like pregnancy
themed and so brew i don't know how long
that's gonna go and i didn't want to cut
into his gym time of course of course of
course what's stew's excuse today's
excuse is that his mom literally almost
broke her back like my back and i just
can't be like bending over putting his
harness on lifting him up like i will
throw my back out got it i'm so close
like i have to be so careful okay
well you should use one of the chirp um
oh i should actually it's here yeah i
don't i just like i need to not move in
between episodes today you could do it
totally a little r r yeah otherwise how
was your week are you excited for your
trip tomorrow i am i spent all day
yesterday like getting ready and you
know what
i'm really sick of it
of what
the fashion industry
let me just tell you
because i have been i've gotten really
good in my old age about not leaving
things to the last minute like i'm i'm
really good about ordering things online
in advance
for big events in my life and so for
this wedding i have a shabbat i have a
western party like a pre-dinner
pre-wedding thing and then an actual
wedding and for months i've been
ordering stuff and just i guess it all
caught up to me like i never actually
got anything that i liked i returned
everything i ordered online so yesterday
i was forced to go shopping
in person which is literally the the
worst like the worst
and i'm just [ __ ] sick of the
industry first of all like when did
everyone stop making beautiful things
like everything is ugly and everything
is meant to be like the vibe these days
is like a little house on the prairie
like nap dresses like where are the real
dresses like for real women oh my god
it's like it's like that stretchy
material over your boobs and big puffy
sleeves like that's all they make now
yeah why
i don't know
and so i just went everywhere
and it was so disheartening one because
everything's so ugly and two like all
they do is carry sizes it's literally
mean girls like i went to four different
stores and they were all one three five
you could try sears literally and i'm
like where is the nearest sears it's
just
it's out of control like until there is
a store that sells beautiful things in
lots of sizes like i'm done yeah i mean
the beautiful things is step one you
know because like that's out the door
out the door like the way that we all
dress now is
disgusting
shameful and myself included look at me
i'm what am i wearing like sweat shorts
today same it's just like a sad state of
an affair i went to sax which like when
you go to certain stores you know you're
gonna spend more and i was so desperate
i was like okay so i try on this dress
and i didn't really look at anything
because i was like let me find a dress
that fits and that i like first and then
i'll deal with how i'm going to pay for
it and i found this dress and it was so
stunning i didn't even send you a
picture because it was valentino
it was just a red dress it was not even
special like valentina
high heels red dress no it was high
heels
red dress red nose
high heels high heels red dress red
dress
part of the song wearing the better part
i like i like the so it was like a very
nothing dress but like a flattering
piece of cloth it didn't have
embellishments it was literally just a
red dress
guess how much it was valentino yeah
three thousand dollars
nine hundred dollars
i was like why am i in this store and i
couldn't even you were on the wrong
floor sister i was on the gowns floor
and like i saw dresses of all different
prices and i was trying everything on
never did i think i would go into the
high four figures i was like this is a
joke and this is what it cost to get a
decent dress it was by no means stunning
it was just a flowy red dress
i was shocked that's crazy so i just
like and that's why my back is broken by
the way like literally
and they realize these are not real
problems i just
this is my podcast and i feel like
complaining
and i asked you how your week was going
and what you're up to where are the
beautiful things and until i find said
beautiful things i'm done i'm done
i feel you
and i go and i got stuff and i'm just
like not particularly in love with any
of my looks for this weekend right which
is why there's such an emphasis on glam
because with
good hair and makeup you can really turn
it out that is very true you know yeah
because the clothes are just not cutting
it these days no oh my god like and i
would love some recommendations like
first of all i was like okay i need to
go shopping in the city like where do we
go
and it's just like department stores
yeah
it's been a while for me no i know i
never shop in person now i actually do
have to go shopping like for my
burgeoning physique
yes you do you know revolve has
maternity i searched maternity and
revolved which is where i got my
maternity jeans and a pair of leggings
um
that was it did it work for you or no no
no no but i actually i was actually
excited to share the news in my
pregnancy because now i like i could use
some like maternity clothes
recommendation stores if you guys know
of any i just have to say i don't know
how people like went through pregnancy
before the internet like i feel like i'm
always hearing about especially like the
toast groups for pregnant moms or moms
who are trying um literally like saving
their lives during pregnancy and i'm
like what did people do before the
internet yeah just as for the cave women
no there's literally everything
available at all times which is so
fantastic totally i feel like honestly
amazon probably has really good
maternity for sure but i i also haven't
thought about what i want my maternity
style to be because i could just like
buy clothes that i like in just larger
sizes
i just i don't know
i don't know and like i'm not someone
who wears like long dresses or anything
but that's very like you know maternity
chic i think that the maternity vibe
that like i probably will
literally be into my pants all the time
so don't take this for me but like if i
had to choose a maternity aesthetic it
would be kim pregnant with
saint
yeah but she was komodos and body con
dresses where am i wearing a [ __ ]
body contrast i don't wear that not
pregnant all of a sudden it's just such
a good look i understand yeah if i'm
ever going to a conference i will
definitely wear that no well we're
planning a trip in like two months
you'll probably have a small bump no i'm
not concerned about like the more
like dressing up but like for everybody
what the [ __ ] am i wearing i don't know
i feel like blouses like i don't know
yeah maybe like my maternity jeans and
like button-down shirts
yeah honestly like i think a lot about
how you know i hope obviously one day
knock on wood to be pregnant um and i
have like some people i know you can't
time anything
but like your timeline is really ideal
for me because like i don't want to be
my absolute largest in the warm months
yeah you know i was thinking about this
and that's what most people say but like
the first three months
are really difficult and so like being
so
being in the first three months like in
hot sweaty august like where the trash
cans on the street smells so bad like
there's all these different smells and
like things that are just triggering i
don't think there's ever a good time but
i'm like
i'm feeling this more than than usual
but i think i would feel it in second or
third too that's an interesting take as
well yeah i just feel like the message
here is like there's never a good time
to be in your first trimester in new
york city in new york city that's what's
the message i think that if we lived in
iowa and we had fields of like lilies
and we would just be so excited to go
outs outside and smell them i think the
message is there's never a good time to
be in new york city yeah not even the
pregnant part just like living here 100
though if there is a time that's better
than the other [ __ ] times it's christmas
oh
fall christmas you think yeah but then
you get like snow that's dirty that's
true
like the dirty gray snow that they never
clean up
i don't know we're gonna have a new
mayor soon like maybe that'll be a
priority of his and like maybe christmas
in new york will be fabulous again oh my
gosh that's something to look forward to
that is but not this christmas it would
be for next christmas [ __ ] oh my god
next christmas i gave you my hug
i love i'm just
i'm telling you jackie
if i don't see the snow by christmas
like you will never see me again like i
will have lost my mind i know the
feeling i'm every day on street easy
like looking and it's just such a tough
market right now
everything listed today gone tomorrow 10
applications for an overpriced apartment
that has like ugly toilets yeah
i'm just realizing like in order to get
what i want to get
i'm gonna have to give something up and
i think i'm gonna have to give up my
closet
like my closet is so sickening and in
these new apartments like with my budget
i'm not gonna be able to have a
sickening closet you know i actually had
to give up some closet when i moved and
it's it was tough but i'm glad i moved
yeah right yeah and like i could do with
some cleansing mm-hmm
and i'm going to do with a lot of
cleansing because you're always
complaining that you have nothing to
wear i know a huge closet so i'm going
to have to give that up i also think i
might have to give up my dream of having
outdoor space i do too
but i need a tub and i need light and
windows and i found a great apartment
that like literally they're so sneaky
you know
like this gorgeous apartment they make
these fancy photos that are renderings
by the way they're not even real photos
of the apartment
and i was emailing with her and you know
for me it's like i before i go down and
check out an apartment like i need to be
absolutely certain that it's right for
me because i'm not wasting my time
so i ask a lot of questions and i know
that the realtors on street easy hate
that and then i'm just like wait i'm
like zooming in on these pictures i'm
like i think this is good like i think i
could go see this apartment zooming in
on these pictures and they like put up
fake drapes and i'm like what's behind
the drapes
brick walls everywhere like there's no
views
they literally trick you into come
coming to see the apartment that's wild
it's and then i found another apartment
and i was like loving it real wrote to
the broker and i've read in the
description she's like these photos are
not of this apartment they're of a
different apartment okay but is it the
same unit same line no
i was like because i'm thinking like the
floor plan doesn't match the pictures
they just they just don't put up
pictures like that's how easy the
brokers have it now because people are
so desperate i will not be desperate and
make a desperate move you should reach
out to ramona i feel like ramona does
sales um
you should just reach out to her i
should just in general she definitely
like knows of some good properties i was
also thinking i should reach out to
ramona when i was watching real
housewives of new york yesterday because
i feel like she would love spritz
right like i feel like we need to get
like a big delivery to her home for all
of her parties yeah that's a good call
i'm gonna tell ben okay cool
um sweet so that's my complaining for
the day i'm done okay great great great
great i don't have much to complain
about just like was so fatigued
yesterday i went to sleep pretty early
um i was reading all day really enjoying
my book i'm like 85 so like
the next 15 percent are just gonna be
pure enjoyment uh which i'm excited
about it's called rules of civility by
amar amore tolls
and yeah then i'll have to get a new
book for this weekend so send me any
recs yeah i was going to start eliza
starts a rumor but i think i like really
want to save the whole thing for the
plane you know okay cool cool
i'm excited for you you've got a lot of
good stuff lined up so i guess without
further a do to do moment of silence for
doing brew
it is time for the fast life stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
spritz society sportsociety.com
as you guys know last week we launched
our very own beveragino and jackie is
pregnant so unfortunately she can
indulge in it but i can and it's a
fabulous sparkling wine canned cocktail
called sports society they're available
at spritsociety.com they come in four
flavors uh pineapple grapefruit lemonade
and blood orange everyone has their own
favorites i'm so excited to see everyone
getting their packages and we have a
code toast that is ten percent off a
variety pack so if you go to
spritsociety.com
toast ten percent off on all four
flavors check it out spritz society.com
code toast or spritsociety.com
toast yes enjoy
i love seeing everyone getting their
spirit society and trying it and doing
like taste tests such a vibe it's such a
vibe and you should really treat
yourself to some spirit society and you
got to try them all you know because
everybody has a different favorite it's
the craziest thing it's literally like
the pokemon beverages gotta try them all
that's what i'm saying by the way
speaking of trope um
trope in the like torah sense yesterday
when we were singing beautiful stunning
and smart we are
k-r-s cars for kids
me too and i hope that that's a national
commercial i do believe it is i don't
think it's a tri-state area commercial i
believe it has national distribution
because if you don't know that jam since
literally the early 90s like you ain't
living yeah so that was really funny
that we were it was in my head all day
yesterday beautiful stunning and this is
where we are this is a great reminder
that if you have a car that you want to
donate go to 1877 cards for kids.com
code toast because and you get a free
tax deduction or something i don't know
what the kids are doing with those cars
the whole charity makes no sense i don't
i don't know even what the how do the
cars help the kids
i don't know they can't drive no maybe
they like
i have no idea it's a mystery i'm sure
it's not but like they don't really
clarify the commercial why these kids
need cars i know and like we're just so
distracted by these stunning campers
like just rocking out with their fake
instruments
it's it's a genius marketing move it
really is
okay first story honey boo boo is back
she is on the cover of teen vogue
talking about drugs body shaming and
having no friends no
yeah really sad
she well that part sounds sad but the
whole article she's back and she's
better than ever
honey boo boo like we've never seen her
before she's mentioning it all to teen
vogue she said my mama did not name me
honey boo boo my name is ilana oh she's
done with the boo boo i guess so i mean
this is probably the time you know you
when you go from lizzie mcguire to
hillary clinton montana and miley cyrus
honey boo boo to alana i mean i've been
waiting for this like kind of expose not
expose profile profile on alana because
i really feel like she is an american
hero and i love her and i just feel like
she was here and then she was gone do
you know what i mean yeah and we never
really got an explanation or a follow-up
as to what went on even though they're
very like
public with everything like they have a
show for everything i just feel like i
still don't really know what went on
yeah i think that article is clearing
some of that up but also i wonder what's
next like this clearly seems like you
know step one in relaunching alana i
wonder what step 10 is where are we
headed yeah no i mean she's literally
like
made for television
and
i just know that this is not the end for
her like i really believe that in my
bones this these pictures this
everything feels like the beginning of
something gorgeous honestly i loved the
direction of the entire shoot i thought
it was so her i love that they put her
in like minimal makeup she's a child
like she's turning 16. she's a child she
was wearing what looked like morphy too
like charlie demilio makeup i thought
she looked gorgeous and i just love her
and i think everyone who worked on this
shoe like great message great photos
great art direction i'm a huge honey boo
boo fan like huge yeah and i just feel
like our time has come it's coming it's
coming i do feel like the resurgence of
alana honey boo boo is on its way me too
and this was a great start so congrats
to her pr team excellent um really great
choo choo check out cover yeah check out
the article if you're interested to know
what miss booboo has been up to i know
and if
you really are bored they have a show on
wetv and it's it's nothing like it was
you know
that couple seasons where they had the
tlc show
here comes honey boo boo
was really
a cultural reset
and it was so good because they didn't
give us [ __ ] like they had nothing to
lose they were
totally authentically themselves even
when it was like gross like they were
putting mayo like up their butts like it
was really gross but it was like i feel
like in 20 years like if somebody you
know like if i
if somebody who time traveled from 100
years ago like came and watched that
television show like they wouldn't
understand it like that's how
transformative it was
yeah
yeah really great and i stand by and you
know what's so crazy like i always
forget
that whole family came from
toddlers and tiaras like she was like a
breakout star on that show and then they
got their own that show was crazy that
was like a crazy time for tlc yeah now i
feel like tlc is like really focused on
like
like medicine like dr pimple popper my
600 pound life like surgeries like
they're very like
kind of gross like with like we're
always getting like
surgery visuals like which make me
nauseous yeah i don't feel like they're
into like the weird and crazy anymore
well i think they're still into that
but you're right they definitely have a
medical focus yes like the medical
department has blown up what's the name
of the doctor for myself dr nazardan i
[ __ ] love him i [ __ ] love him and
i will never not i will never just like
scroll past a meme about him like i will
always give it my time and my energy
because he is so and there's like if you
go on youtube and watch like dr nazar dr
nazaren's like most savage moments it's
such a joy i saw one recently that was i
literally sent it to everyone in my life
i was laughing so hard he goes very
wrong tic tac and you know i don't even
know if he knows like what a figure in
pop culture he is because he's just so
humble and like just does his job keeps
his head down lives in houston but like
literally at my next birthday party like
i am having like a special appearance by
doctor and his arden and then he's gonna
give me something to roast you and then
he's gonna give me surgery yeah like if
i'm ever gonna get weight loss surgery
like i'm going to the best you would go
to him 100
houston yeah
done cool and like i've seen people
who like cut out get like cardboard
cutouts of them or like huge magnets of
him and put it on the refrigerator to
like help with their dieting and i feel
like it's an effective method for sure
you know whatever works whatever works
i've not seen that but also i'm not you
know on the top you're not on the doctor
in his art and stan kind of for you
paige and it's literally me and olivia
olivia is here i would love to be there
i'll send you well you don't have to
talk but maybe if i find something on
reels i'll send it to you thanks girlie
you and olivia have been sending me i
don't know if olivia listens to the
toast but like i put that energy out
she's been sending me reels that like i
literally saw on tic tac i'm not even
serious like a year ago like she sent me
one this morning like you know
jen's ears will never understand like
the feeling of being a millennial like
hearing levels in a club i'm like olivia
like this went viral like like i'm
embarrassed for you like six months ago
i also can't believe that that's like
the kind of content she sends around
yeah it was very on olivia i was
wondering if she was like trying to tell
me something i don't know she was hacked
totally
okay our next story is a little beauty
news ariana grande wait if you ever get
hacked i really hope that the person
who hacks you changes your username to
hackie ashrae
free idea that's how we'll know if you
got hacked okay cool ariana grande's rem
beauty line is coming soon here's what
we know try and remain calm but ari is
launching a beauty line and according to
a new billboard in times square it's all
about to happen very soon the singer
caused quite the tizzy after she created
an instagram account and website for rem
beauty which seems to be a reference to
her song rem from her album sweetener
the acronym stands for rapid eye
movement i wish that her last name began
with an m because then it would be r-e-n
i know when you said to me ariana is
launching a makeup line called rem i was
like oh ari like
yeah like it's confusing that's
interesting maybe it's our re
makeup
that's cute yeah because rem is like
your sleep site sleep cycle so what does
that have to do with makeup also i do
feel like if i looked at ari's catalog
of everything she's done there might be
a better name for a makeup company in
there even like sweetener makeup
100
also like rem is obviously a sleep cycle
and i feel like makeup is supposed to
make you look like alive and awake and
like why are you gonna
use the sleepy makeup yeah no i just i
feel like there could be
better options well i have to say i feel
very like on the fence about certain
celebrity makeup lines because now it
seems like a cash grab
but every now and then like you have a
real success like fenty rare beauty is a
smash like everyone loves it and the
products are very good you've used it
yes
and it's counselor loves it and everyone
on tiktok loves it like it is a bonafide
success like you it's going to be the
thing that selena gomez retires on like
but then you have like halsey's line
which we never heard about again even
i'm sorry like house laboratories from
lady gaga like flop central um
kesha released one floppy o like there
there's more flops than there are
successes but you never know and ariana
grande does have like a very signature
look yes that
i do think that this could be really
popular i agree she's also at a level of
fame that i thought for you know lady
gaga so famous like no matter what she
does like it should be a success so
that's why like house laboratory is
flopping like was kind of
shocking but ari's at that level now
where like she just farts and it's like
you know yeah and it's just it's a new
perfume scent
literally sold exclusively at ulta yeah
so i think that no matter what this will
be successful but also i don't think
it's a terrible idea like she does have
a signature makeup look she does and i i
can already envision like it's an easy
sell to think about what she's going to
be producing like obviously
the eyeliner hopefully she'll do some
hair products too because yeah like
whatever pomade she's using like
bottleneck for my salad need for my
frizzy ass bun today yeah yeah so i i
don't think this is the worst idea i've
ever heard um i just i want a little
more clarity on the name
yeah well right now i think they're in
that marketing stage of like mystery
here's a name right right what we're
doing everyone's going into like you
know detective mode the account has 65
000 followers but has never posted
and they follow like joan follows it and
her makeup artist follows it you know
it's definitely like legit
but it's just an interesting
like alicia keys did skin care right i
don't remember hearing about it but that
was like the best idea yeah no i think
was makeup too no that was like the
thing like that she she doesn't wear
makeup
right so i think at first people thought
it was makeup and we're like what and
then it's like skincare it's like oh
that's actually really on brand for her
i'm like authentic yeah then i never
heard about it again i don't even know
if it came out yet yeah and then like a
rod has a makeup line he's
gotta stop oh jlo skin that was like
floppy central i don't know just because
like you don't use it no it's not use it
see it like i watched so much beauty
tick tock like i never see someone i'm
gonna prep my face with the chain love
skin primer like i've never seen that
yeah yeah so if it never comes across my
desk in tutorials or like if it's only
on their social media like that's how
you know it's a flop you're going to
call that a flop okay yeah i think
that's fair i think the biggest flop i
don't even know if it ever came out is
halsey's like i
i didn't even know that it was brewing
there was like a lot i think she did
like a youtube video with
like a big
youtuber that's what they all do lady
gaga did nikki tutorials um selena gomez
did also nikkietutorials i think and
then she like popped up in everyone's
videos like she facetimed in remember
right
and that and
i don't even i don't follow selena gomez
on any platforms i see rare beauty
everywhere like especially on tick tock
everyone's always using it the blushes
went viral like sorry it's a success you
know i need a new blush okay so like
their pigment in blush has been viral
and like i bought it because i'm a
follower and a loser
and
i don't like that margot loves it you
put it on your cheek and you're supposed
to it's like very pigmented so you put
like a tiny little liquid dot it is so
pigmented you look like a clown and like
where you put the dot it like leaves a
mark i'm good you know i really am good
on the reinventing of blush like it's
literally probably been the it's like
the first cosmetic ever created the
rouge and if it ain't broke don't fix it
like do you like a powder blush i like a
powder brush blush i just want something
that's like the perfect color for me
it's really not that hard like i agree
to go to sephora i agree like i actually
had one and then i dropped it i'm pretty
sure with charlotte tilbury and had a
little bit of highlighter on the rim i
have that too it's like a it looks like
flush in the period it obviously looks
like a like a vulva a full stop
okay sure blush in the middle
rim
of highlight it's a written it's the rim
job highlighter
yes i have that charlotte it's
delightful it's delightful and then i
dropped it because of bruno okay what do
you think is the most popular makeup
brand out there right now
the most popular
[Music]
i mean i know for me what i use the most
no but like in culture
maybe um
maybe fenty beauty or i just need to
think of the aisles at sephora just give
me a minute i mean urban decay is really
popular it's like a little dated it's
not popular with the kids on tick tok
like milk
no honestly it's charlotte tilbury
glossier it's charlotte tilbury like i
can tell you her stick she has like the
contour stick the highlighting wand and
the blush
changed the makeup game forever and when
i'm on tick tock every single person's
entire skincare routine not skincare
sorry face base is charlotte tilbury the
foundations the hollywood flawless
filter those wands it's crazy how
charlotte tilbury in the last two years
became the biggest makeup brand in the
world it's because she like makes
amazing videos that make her products
look delicious like i want to eat them
yes like i want to take a bite out of
the models shiny glazed donuts
yeah but then you just realize like it's
because like she's gorgeous and i'm
fugly yes and the products no matter how
much charlotte tiller i put on my face i
don't look like her the products work
but not in the same way that they did on
the model and that's just like something
we have to live with that's something we
have to live with no the brand that i
use the most if i can only like use one
brand and it's like probably 60 of what
i use is nars
really [ __ ] love knives i think it's
like perfect yeah i feel like it's a
little dated and i don't think the kids
are using nars but like no i love nars
yeah nars and mac are like
so i don't use old school i've never
safely say i don't use mac yeah i've
never used mac
it's just interesting to think about it
is interesting to think about are you
ready for our next story though yeah
thinking about something else olivia
rodrigo is adding paramore writing
credit to good for you
olivia rodrigo is giving credit where
it's due and it's due to paramours
hayley williams and joshua farrow the
songwriters have apparently just learned
that the 18 year old pop star has added
their names to the songwriting credit
for her recent hint good for you a song
that debuted at number one in the us
it's not clear when their names were
added to the track notes however they
were not reportedly there when the song
was first released a few months ago fans
observed early the similarities between
the song and paramore's 2007 single
misery business musical mashups
comparing the two songs appeared on
social media accusing rodrigo of being
heavily inspired by the punk pop punk
group drawing in millions of viewers in
the process
yeah so i think like you know for months
we've all been saying like it sounds a
lot like paramore and like olivia's
definitely influenced by power more yeah
and what's interesting is that like a
lot of her songs from this
album sound like other songs but it's
because she sampled like new year's day
from taylor swift she sampled the bailey
eilish song so each artist that she was
influenced by like gets a piece of their
song because she's using
a sample but with this one there wasn't
one and this one was like really the
most obvious one
like what she did it's the same melody
so that's why she had to give them
songwriting credits but also i read
somewhere and i don't know if this is
true or not that before the song came
out like she her and her management team
were talking with like paramore and the
paramore management team like about how
similar the songs were so i don't think
there's any bad blood by any means i
feel like also haley williams is like so
mature yeah like she supports other
women yeah but i'm sure now she's like
making a good amount of money from the
song yeah they do sound really similar
and i mean all this time like you see
those videos i've been seeing them on
reels of like six months later
millennials who are like
no wonder this sounds familiar and then
it's like a flashback to them like in
their emo phase of paramore and i was
just always thought that was like a
funny trend but i guess it was like just
another reminder to olivia rodrigo like
to add these people as songwriting
credits i mean like
a lot of songs sound the same like
that's just life because there are only
so many you know keys on a piano but
this one was i think like unavoidably
similar yeah so
congrats to paramore yeah i just want to
say like i and i've seen like a lot of
like old men like on the internet
talking about how like you know
like olivia rod i don't i just i don't
feel like this takes away from
olivia rodriguez like talent or success
just like the fact that a lot of her
songs like sound like other songs i
think she's admittedly like been
obsessed with pop music her whole life
so this is like the influence like i
don't think it is bad mm-hmm and i don't
think it takes away from like what she's
done no me neither i have to listen to
other songs but to me when i listen to
the album like the first time i heard it
i was like oh this one really sounds
like that but yeah so we got two great
songs so the misery business [ __ ]
slaps like so now we have a 2021 version
like literally like if you're ever in my
presence at a karaoke bar and misery
business come or honestly anything power
more like stay away stay away far yeah i
agree such a good song such a good song
and now it's back in like the
culture because of good for you so i'm
not complaining have you ever seen the
video of haley williams like it was like
an iphone video of her in the studio
recording
i should be over all the butterfly have
you seen the video it's like her true
vocals that ended up being in the song
it's she's such a crazy voice like it's
exactly the same like itunes it's the
craziest video it's on my list of videos
i go down and watch you know nice nice i
need to start an official playlist
you should i know share it with everyone
yeah that sounds cool
uh next story little tik tok news tick
tock is issuing a warning against the
milk crate challenge amid reports of
injuries across the country milk crate
you this one
it's a crate that's like what you used
to use in i called the milk crate
challenge and even i knew that it's
called the crate challenge it's called
the milk crate it's called everyone's
been calling it the milk crate i can't
believe that you've missed that okay
when you look at those crates though
what do you think milk i think textbooks
yeah that's because they're reused milk
crates but they eventually they
initially started they're not reusable
you get them at staples no you don't you
don't
build one of these for textbooks but
like when you have an extra one you use
it for your textbooks
i don't originally started with milk um
listen everybody's calling the milk
crate challenge like you're just way
behind on the times i thought it was the
crate challenge but okay whatever yeah
but it's short for milk right okay the
milk crate challenge involves people
climbing up and down an unsecured
pyramid made out of milk crates which
often ends in a catastrophic fall and
tick tock is putting its foot down amid
growing reports of injuries sustained
while participating in the viral stupid
trend it's [ __ ] moronic i'm sorry if
you have participated in this challenge
like you're a [ __ ] in a statement to
people on wednesday a tick-tock
spokesperson says soon claudia is going
to be like gathering all the milk crates
in the building no oh my god me are you
serious like so uncoordinated don't have
any semblance of balance like even
people who are hyper athletic like are
falling off on like the third row and
like literally breaking their backs on a
milk crate the clutter they going viral
maybe that's how you broke your back
yesterday you were trying to do the milk
crate at home so
in a statement to people on wednesday a
tick tock spokesperson says that the app
prohibits content that promotes or
glorifies dangerous acts and we remove
videos and redirect searches to our
community guidelines to discourage such
content we encourage everyone to
exercise caution in their behavior
whether online or off good this is like
when people were being stupid on
instagram or twitter and like eating
tide pods like at some point the
platform has a responsibility to stop
this
aside behavior uh i don't know if that's
on the platform like people just like
you're responsible for yourself and if
you want to be a big idiot like go for
it of course but like the fact that
these videos are going viral adds
incentive for people to do it so like
tik tok is
inadvertently like influencing people to
do it because of the cloud it gives them
so like if they're removing the the
cloud element who's going to [ __ ]
just start climbing up a staircase made
of milk crates that's true
but it's like if they're naturally going
viral because it's so entertaining but i
mean it is like everyone i come across
like i watch in full because i've only
seen one person completed successfully
and what was like
what do you think what the method was i
don't know because he looked like he was
doing it just like everyone else just
like slowly
one to the next yes but like when you
put one foot
on the crate you have to like balance
your weight
because and your your for the first foot
that goes has to be in the middle of the
crate
to balance
where do you put the second foot this
conversation is making me want to try it
i'll make you one no stop again i'm
pregnant no i know it's so stupid but
like i saw a video of like literally
thousands of people gathered in
washington square park
that's watching people do it taking
turns
and when you fall the entire milk crate
pyramid underneath you crumbles yeah and
then you're forced to land from like 10
feet in the air onto crates it's so
stupid so stupid i'm sorry like this is
where i just don't feel like i belong in
my culture like what are we doing yeah
do not do it you guys don't even if her
description made it seem like i wonder
if i could do it please don't try it
you know do something else with your
time read a book join the redheads join
the redheads if only everyone
participating in the milk challenge
joined the redheads read a book try
girls no job the crazy beautiful life of
an instagram thirst monster anytime's
best-selling novel written by this
podcast host claudia ashrae available
anywhere ebook hardcover audiobook all
of the places yes exactly that is a good
use of your time yes educational now are
you ready for our fifth and final story
that's going to lead into the tv recap
is it the final story
[Music]
[Music]
beautiful
that's really stunning yes what's the
fifth and final the final story is
brought to you by patreon.com
the morning toast where we deliver
premium content every month to you a
little bonus content a little more
personal content behind the scenes vlogs
q and a's about all different subject
matters interviews with some of our
friends and family and then once you're
a patron you can request some of the
interviews and episodes that you want to
see so patreon.com morning toast it's
the best way to support our show and
it's a 7.99 a month for bonus content
that is truly premium we and also the
best part about it is that if you sign
up today you've got access to all the
episodes that we've ever done and there
are some gems in there like drunk get
ready with us who remembers that one and
the uh you had access to toast after
dark oh which is the last remaining
facebook group where people are so
warm just
a fabulous group of people but it's
really crazy to think about some of the
episodes that we've done like
that were just so funny you know what
came up in my time hobby yesterday when
we went to walmart we did walmart like
shop with us and then we did a little
mukbang with ben
good times we still need to do our
mukbang sure maybe next weekend we are
going to take a trip a road trip we are
yeah oh yeah for labor day yeah yeah
um so yeah there's just like such fun
stuff so check it out then final story
tom jordy's law firm owes 101 million
dollars in debt new bankruptcy case
filing reveals this is [ __ ] crazy
not to victims to creditors per
documents obtained by people the total
liabilities for the once famed
powerhouse attorney's law firm geordi
keith comes in at over 101 million
dollars roughly 97 million more than the
total assets of all listed property the
documents state that the trustee
handling gerardi keys chapter 7
bankruptcy case has filed to amend the
schedule of his assets and liabilities
the trustee reviewed the firm's books
and records in preparation noting that
quote the debtor's accounting offices
were not well maintained and that much
of what the trustee found upon her
appointment was very dated a lawyer for
tom's conservator and a representative
for gerardi keith did not respond to
content comments yeah i mean i just feel
like every time we open up you know the
newspaper it's just worse and worse not
only are they like you know
stealing resettlement money from orphans
and widows but they're also running like
a fraudulent business where like they're
taking money from creditors and unable
to pay back yeah it's like the women
said last week there he was running his
firm like a ponzi scheme yes but you
know what like if if the only
thing that
he was guilty of was running a
fraudulent thing and stealing money from
creditors like
it's like it's not a victimless crime
but it's
no it's less
it's less atrocious than the crime right
that's just like a white-collar crime
where like you know he's a classic
businessman who goes to jail but like
this is like you are an evil person yes
yes yes orphans widows burn victims yes
so let's get into
real house has a beverly hills recap
it's really crazy because if real
housewives of beverly hills wasn't
airing right now and every week and
every day you open the newspaper and
these news things are gonna be so
frustrating right gerardi keys no i
would just be like they cannot
she will never get out of this but like
she's doing some real damage control on
the show and really making people
question like
what did she know what did she know and
i mean
i feel like her reaction to sutton she's
very defensive at like the first person
who hasn't like blindly supported
supported her and poked you know holes
in her story do you think her very kind
of defensive reaction to sutton proves
her innocence or proves her guilt
i think it's an easy reaction to have um
i think
neither i think that the women who came
to her and said sutton's worried about
her reputation we're misrepresenting
sutton's concerns and making it seem
very small and that's so easy for erica
to call her out on and be like a small
town and because that's true if someone
if one of your close friends is in
trouble and you don't want to be by her
side because of your reputation like how
small are you are we friends or are you
that's not what's up but that's not what
sutton said like maybe that's one small
piece of why sutton is concerned in
general but it's not because of what the
neighbors will think no she was very
clear
like
in
participating in this charade with erica
all of the women are inserting
themselves into a very serious
[ __ ] up legal situation also it's
important to keep in mind that like
sudden isn't completely wrong because as
of recently and this was filmed like
months ago but recently bravo has been
subpoenaed for footage so like this does
involve like the network and the women
so sutton is not wrong and wanting to
protect herself
like worried that you know her friends
are gonna think ill of her because she's
friends with erica who's in legal
trouble they might think over because
she's involved in now this legal trouble
also there is an element of like you
know everyone here has a conscience and
a moral compass and like could you live
with yourself if you didn't ask
questions you just like believed
everything erica said when of course she
has a lot to protect so there's also
that element too and i really do not
fault sutton at all i just don't know if
sutton is
strong enough when it comes to
confrontation to be able to adequately
tell her side or what she's feeling and
then again that's next week they get
into it and they're sitting next to each
other again and it just makes no [ __ ]
sense it makes no sense so they're both
talking to each other like this
with sutton like when she's going
toe-to-toe with someone you're like you
know just rooting for her to be able to
get her words out i think with every
situation she's getting stronger me too
and the way that eric is like really so
dismissive of her like that's like
we see a little we saw a little bit of
it at the brenda beauty party just like
she says something and then like goes
back she's just very dismissive of
sutton and it happens again next week i
do think that is gonna fuel sutton like
she doesn't like to be treated like
she's irrelevant because it's actually
so rude the way that erica speaks to her
yeah
no i think that
i i mean i i i think that most of the
viewers are team sutton in this
situation what do people believe like i
would love to know so i don't know i i
look on twitter after like some of the
more heated episodes to see where
everyone's had and every single tweet is
is sutton and garcelle are the queens
sudden garcelle and crystal like are the
investors not really
says she really says nothing yeah sutton
garcelle are really putting the you know
the defense
the prosecution on their back who do you
think pays for a party for winter beauty
at crystal's house there's no way
crystal pays for that maybe production
pays for it because it's like they need
a setting in order to like what did they
even launch they just had lunch no i was
also like i thought they all got there
early to talk and then like the party
would start but like literally all of
that for seven people to have lunch
ridiculous i was more
wondering when crystal throws three
parties a week for her friends she's
paying for three parties a week well
yeah for sure but like this is not her
party it's rina's and this is just a
venue yeah but
so rina beauty launched like when with
that lunch right like when did the
website go live i don't know i don't
know but i i don't think i don't follow
rena so if but then i checked out
brandon beauty last night and i guess
it's all like it's all there there's a
lot of content okay good yeah um the
fight between garcelle and dory was like
frustrating because i really do like
both of them and i need them to just
like stop this nonsense i do feel like
part of dorit's reasoning for starting
this random fight was one because she
has been like kind of irrelevant i think
that she needed something like
nonsensical to like dig her teeth into
but also like garcelle like has been
making those digs so it was like an easy
thing to
bring up to bring up but i didn't really
understand
garcelle's response okay so like
garcelle said like yes i have said these
things to you and the reason is is
because i feel like you talk a lot but
none of what she said had anything to do
with with jerry being chatty and i just
want to say we've been watching the show
for years and i've never once gotten the
vibe that dorita's chat because they cut
her [ __ ] out but the fact that every
single person has said it at some point
it must be so true yeah um no so here's
what i was thinking i feel like when
dorite is talking she's so long-winded
and like so let's go instance by
instance because they're all different
when she said to darit that's not what
you said at
that's not what you said on saturday
night i said that three times i said it
three times because darie was trying to
ignore it yeah and i was like it's crazy
that garcelle said it three times it's
like annoying but like dream wouldn't
have responded if
if she didn't stop saying it yeah
because she was ignoring it also
bringing up palm springs like was not
cool
not cool at all but so doreen is talking
so long when it's so long landed so
long-winded and then garcelle is just
like let's get to the meat of it that's
not what you said saturday night right
no and like you're going to leave so and
garcelle and saturn are friends so it's
like you're going to leave sutton out
here to like be killed by erica all
alone when you were also the one like
fanning the flames yeah with sutton i
agree so that to me like that story
talking a lot and like let's get to the
point yeah you didn't say that saturday
night yeah the other instance that she
brought up was something about you would
never take sutton science inside but i
also think again like if darie's talking
in circles and then like in order to
just cut through the [ __ ] you need to
just be like you would never do you know
what i mean like honestly now it seems
like both i forget what the third
example was but like now two out of the
times
where garcelle made jobs that's at
to read it had to do with like
protecting sutton
yeah i just think sometimes when dory
you know is trying to make a point but
she wants to couch her language because
she doesn't want the blow to land so
hard she just talks around herself and
so garcelle is bringing her back too but
you didn't say that yeah yeah yeah the
only thing is it's like garcia like if
you're gonna say [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you get up and leave just to sit back
down that's like a weak move no i think
walking out when you're being confronted
is a weaker weaker move of course but if
you're already up like no i didn't just
sit back
no i disagree if she had left it would
have been like can't deal with being
called out like you know denise style
every single time someone brought
something up denise left so she stood up
to let everyone know she's she's
frustrated but she sat back down because
she can handle this conversation i just
think like if you're going to commit
commit no i was glad that it didn't end
that way because then everyone would be
like garcelle and then it's all about
girls then it's over yes like i um
i very much like to read and garcelle
and i just thought dorite was like
coming out of nowhere and no she needed
something to do like she's been so
irrelevant i agree and also
i mean she must really talk a lot for
everyone to have said it over the course
of different seasons and it's never
like i'm gonna try and talk less
yeah and to me that it like i i mean i
love to read as a housewife but like as
a friend person that i would know that
is probably one of the most annoying
traits of someone i agree he talks and
talks and talks and doesn't say anything
yeah no and also doesn't let room for
other people i realize the irony in me
saying that yes i do you're usually
saying something like there are people
who just get lost in the lingo yeah and
i like and i think it happens like in
corporate america all the time where
people just like are just using like
jargon and if they think the longer you
speak the more you seem like you know
what you're talking about and like
i have no time for that like i think the
shorter you can say something the better
the better your message is i have to say
the scene at kathy hilton's house i
found to be really interesting one
because when when she was in her
interviews and she started crying that
like they lost 10 years like first of
all i've never seen kathy hilton cry i
just love to see not that i love her to
be sad i just love seeing a more
emotional side of kathy and when it
comes to like the american woman like
whole thing like i'm fully team kathy
like first of all just like the whole
idea of making a show about your mom is
just like kind of weird like
i understand kathy being like people
have said so much stuff about us over
the years you're gonna give them a whole
tv show to like pick and prod at and
like
kathy's just very protective obviously
of of her mom and i think kyle is in in
a completely different way she thinks
like blowing up her mom's spot like
making a show about her as like an
homage is the way to do that where
kathy's very much like close to the best
like people have said things about us
for so long like let's just like we know
who our mom was like let's leave it
alone right also what i think is so
confusing about what kyle says it's like
okay so it's based on them growing up
but it's not um
a direct it's not a true story so she
takes these creative liberties but it's
also like we all know the premise for
the show is based on
how how is the viewers supposed to know
that this thing didn't happen but this
thing did and like i actually think that
makes it worse like either be totally
true to the story so there's no room for
like
extrapolation
or
make a show based on someone else at
another time you know i completely
agreed with kathy like being mad at kyle
for that especially if when she had the
idea for the show and started producing
it she was not even on good terms with
her sister like honestly and the show
ended up getting canceled and i'm sure
that's something like all of that just
to get cancelled like i think that
kyle
should and probably does regret doing
that project because everything kathy
was saying i was like facts you know
kathy's like you know funny who's hunky
dory but every now and then she's really
[ __ ] poignant like she's really the
older sister yes and i was just like
living for her she was 100 right like
yeah
first of all not to be rude but who who
is their mom
she's not a famous person right no so
like why would anyone care about a tv
show about her
i don't know that's what i wasn't
understanding like i didn't look into it
i mean there's something like yeah
google it okay well i just i i agreed
with kathy i love her yeah and it was
nice to see her like in her home and the
way that she lives her life she's
dinners ritz crackers look [ __ ] fire
tv dinner
i'm going to buy one i actually got one
recently that i it's a bed um
like eat from bed tray oh my god um i
have to sit up in order like i don't
want to lay in my bed and eat but
because my kitchen smell if you watch
the patreon vlog like i can't even walk
into my kitchen like let alone eat in
there
so i i take my meals in my bedroom most
of the time now and so i had to get a
tray and it's hysterical i need is it
one that like you put over your lap or
okay
i should also get one that stands on the
floor and that like slides under your
bed
oh yeah yeah yeah that's really crazy i
know but like you need one and honestly
in my new apartment i don't think i
can't buy anything for my house until
i'm in a new apartment right but that's
gonna be my first purchase yeah no like
she's really um bringing back tv dinner
trays and they're so like useful no i
know that like little library nook just
looked like a warm fabulous place to eat
a salad on a tv dinner table it did and
i bet her dinner party is going to be
fabulous i can't wait
lanterns i liked what she said about how
dory like does her look that's like
fashion and that's what she's into and
like that kathy does her look on the
table i i i totally understood what she
meant no she's really like a a grown
woman yeah and i think she's elevating
the [ __ ] she was like shading to read at
all and i'm someone who does my look on
myself like
she wasn't shading i don't know but it
was a
made the viewer really understand like
what she's about to put into her table
yeah i am obsessed like she's elevating
this [ __ ] like so hard no yeah in the
beginning i wasn't sure where we were
headed with her as a cast member i
didn't think but now i'm just like i
want actually her to go on my trap
inside and i want annie to ask her
opinion on every single storyline in the
franchise because like i trust her
opinion she's so on point and when she
was just putting on her lipstick when
everyone was fighting and she had no
idea that garcelle was telling everyone
to go [ __ ] themselves she's a queen yeah
i love her yeah um so that's a tv recap
right anything else happened on beverly
hills we need to talk about no
no oh um
and amelia
and the boyfriend and the um
scott
nothing i don't know
delilah boyfriend are cute delilah is
everything like i'm obsessed with her
and her boyfriend's so cute yeah and you
know he's from love island yes but uk
right yes maybe i should go we should go
watch this season you should yeah
um well that's a show
hope everyone enjoyed and yeah that's it
that's it for the week i hope everyone
has an amazing weekend what a fun week
here at the toast if you're all right
it's over if you're rdh that this
episode is ending we are about to film
another one that you can schedule to
watch tomorrow and you won't miss us at
all head over to patreon.com morning
toast so much content so little time
and we will be back in studio on tuesday
yes sorry i'm gone still till monday
because i have wedding tings so we're
back tuesday hope everyone enjoys this
extended weekend
of ours i hope you have a great day
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the past five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as podcasts anywhere podcasts we found
so that's spotify action stitch or
public radio i have rated cast box all
the places where we listen to the
podcast finance morning just leave a
five star you have about beautiful
stunning and smart we are if you're
still here drop an emoji of uh
lipstick
honor of rem beauty
have a great day bye